ميدانيا قالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا تستعد لاجراء تعبئه سريه في الاراضي
المحتله بجزيره القرم على حد تعبيرها
واضافتنا القوات الروسيه تكثف هجومها على
محورين
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قوتها
الجويه
28 غار جويه على مواقع تمركز القوات
الروسيه
بينما شنت القوات الروسيه امس اكثر من
ثلاثين غاره جويه على عده مناطق
من جهتها اعلنت سلطات دوناتس كالمانيا
لروسيا سيطرتها على بلده كليشكا في بخمه
الشرقيه اوكرانيا كما اعلنت مقتل مدني
اثنين في قصف الاوكرانيين استهدف خلال
ساعات الماضيه مناطق خاضعه لسيراتها وقال
مركز الدفاع الاقليمي روسي في دوناتس ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت مناطق جورج لوكا
بنحو 220 صاروخيه ومدفعيه وان مباني سكنيه
عندها تضررت نتيجه القصر